it's Wednesday we're here to talk about
death it's Wednesday man and we want him
in a lot and sad now I just want the
listeners Shawn what happened to me we
should but before you do that for your
listeners who are actually they can't
view this yeah have you been up since
4:00 a.m. I'm glad you asked
I've been up here oh now hold on well
well you know daddy had himself what he
thought was a little staph infection in
the arm and I'll just a preface so
everyone knows what's going on yeah
after we did the show on Monday Brian
goes dude I have staff and I've had
staff a ton of times being a former
mixed martial artist sure you know a lot
of mats yeah had tons of staff yeah and
so I said let me see and you but you had
bandages on yeah I can see it right and
I went do quit being a [ __ ] right I
always do with you cuz your [ __ ] you
know you just your hypochondria Matic
you dramatically a hypochondriac
I tell you if you get a bump on your lip
you're like dude I think I've can't
remember I told you had throat cancer
and I got a throat cancer I called you
had a sore throat I had a little white
spot on my thing but it turned out to be
a piece of food I go to the doctor I
don't see any I was like he's the guy
goes in his room for everything so when
he tells me of these bars yeah I go dude
I've had staff very bad I have friends
who had mercy I've seen it all right
just take antibiotics if you get rid of
it again T it's not that bad any plane
Tanners yeah we're playing grab-ass
boxing so then you go okay I'll do that
so here's here's the--here's now set it
here's the journey thank you before that
for four or five days my arm was killing
me you're falling and I'm said to you I
go I think I don't know where he goes
yeah maybe tennis I got on my elbow my
forearm it's all tender though it feels
like it's tender I couldn't figure it
out and I see these two little spots
this like that like right between so I
do a I do doctor on demand where I have
the guy on you can Skype a doctor cost
75 bucks guys a really nice guy does a
great job goes he looks at it he goes
let me see that bring it up to the
camera he goes you know the way you're
describing it I think you were bit by a
spider I knew it I knew I was bit but
you got the Doogie Howser MD but in a
way you can see because it felt like I'd
been poisoned to little things but also
that could eat coyote Peterson on here
but all
hell yeah we're despite have come from
well you never know dude hey Doc I live
in [ __ ] Playa Vista could have been a
brown look closer my my bad yeah alright
fire like that but the problem is that
thing starts getting pustule E and I'm
like all [ __ ] so I'm like alright
that's nothing no big deal
keep going Brian you're a man keep
boxing keep playing tennis keep lifting
weights like you do at 50 to help keep
rubber by revving high we call it then I
go man I I seem to have a couple of more
of these what looked like pustules which
to spread on the old arm and on the
shoulder so I go oh I got I got me a
case of staff Steffi Stan going to a
walk-in clinic in Marina del Rey guy
comes in casual as can be this last
night now this was on Sunday sir okay
Sunday morning it casual is can be goes
yeah I go but I'm like I might have
mercy I have Steve I'm you know that I'm
like that he's you're not gonna die just
relax no big deal so he gives me bactrim
which is you know a an antibiotic that
takes care of that well I'm taking that
for two days and my pain is worse and
worse weird I'm not able to sleep some
more
up in hot ah each in burning and poster
right on and my right arm and I can't
really lift my arm up like this the [ __ ]
is going on did you Jack honor couldn't
and yep better go the merchants take the
horny right out of me couldn't yank the
old pleasure you can't when you can't
yank your PUD you know you should go
merchants Ihram yes alright so take my
eyes but not my jacket correct so I'm
taking these antibiotics but and now I
got a couple more pustules
all right spreading even more yes sir so
I go well now I have an aggressive form
of flesh-eating bacteria obviously and
measles is popular in well I've had my
measles vaccine doesn't matter right but
I'm definitely gonna shout out to the
anti-vaxxers who are putting all little
infants in danger now but anyway it
doesn't go in yet so don't do that so
now I'm I'm [ __ ] uh I wake up I can't
sleep go to the emergency room I'm sorry
this let me back up this is last night
I'm sorry let me back up can you make
this story clinic I go to another clinic
the USC la Urgent Care they never knows
it they swab it check me for herpes you
can have her
peace on your skin man comes up just
negative you tell them just on my dish
just on my face my dick just on my lips
my face my dick so nothing nothing
negative all right
negative I finally I can't sleep my last
night I go I can't do this I got a whole
day I got to do Rich Eisen in the
morning I got WTF podcast stead of
sleeping is Who I am I Drive myself to
the emergency room now everybody should
see what an emergency room in Los
Angeles looks like at 2:00 a.m. it's the
walking dead oh dude you got a walking
dead so we got you got there's lies in
there with [ __ ] they stuck wd-40 cans
of oh my god mom's in the register
there's drug addict I was drug addicts
on the floor on the floor though they
can't hassle for this day that one guy's
got his head on the chair and you want
to talk about MRSA and real problems
well there's gunshot victims unless it's
in the heart or the stomach you're
waiting you're waiting you're waiting
you're waiting there's gang members oh
yeah white supremacist the whole thing
yes so now I walk but I walk in and I'm
all bunched up and I'm in a gown and
three different nurses come in though I
love those nurses and one of the nurses
comes in one of them was pretty hot
actually is there anything better than a
hot nurse yeah she was very hot
yeah her name is lanique a' ooh shoutout
to Anika yeah Korean or Filipino she's
she's either Filipino african-american
lady oh okay very but but like not only
hot but also wearing perfume that smell
really gone and the big pouty lips the
whole thing on dude you would be very
happy very distract nothing better than
and also there's nothing better we get a
hot nurse and also or a hot flight
attendant yes it will make your flight
yes ooh I could be all the way in the
back in the middle between two fat guys
if the flight attendants hot I'm like
let's do correct all right keep going
and they're all they're all pretty hot
they're all awesome they've all done
this couple times couple one thousand
two thousand times yeah the emergency
nice Gerald with rupee there laughing I
go if I have mercy and she goes soul
Anika goes mouthing is Marissa and then
she waved it off she goes Marissa please
I said laughing it yeah if I can take
care of that with antibiotics I see
crazy [ __ ] I'm like okay oh no
maybe it's staff now I don't think staff
another so so finally another awesome
nurse comes in I believe her name is
Alison working a night shift to working
the night shift Alison comes in looks
and mangoes so you've got her you bet
she goes so you've got shingles honey
and I go excuse me she goes you don't
have staff or mersa or cable acutely we
have shingles no shingles is a virus
doesn't it's in the chicken that contain
antibiotics would have got rid of your
stuff right it's been better not correct
yeah so she goes I go singles the [ __ ]
is that she goes under stress I go I
mean not really I don't we say that but
you all right guess I am are you
[ __ ] me I guess I don't hear your
dirty laundry but you [ __ ] me what
the [ __ ] all right so so so Oh stress
not like all that relax what is saying
no but I mean I dare it so so now all
right so and I drool thank you I know
and I do burn it at both ends I'm doing
everything at the same time so so she
goes yeah you know everybody has it if
you had chicken pox you got shingles so
you know you just got a little thick
case there bring up your image put you
on retrovirals
now sheet now I don't have a bad case of
it she was like oh I said we have it
gets crazy too scary for kids right that
[ __ ] I don't have that that's crazy but
that's what you can deal with bro that's
chicken pox basically maybe some bad
cases you know I've never seen those
chicken pucks like yeah so either way
dude so you get shingles bro so I got
myself so you know what I'm used to felt
good dogs like to figure it out right
yeah [ __ ] it I'll deal with that good
decisions on self limiting your skin
sensitive dude cuz you've had Rice's
psoriasis for 19 years gone that's gone
come get outta come back out it'll rear
ten now you shouldn't be you think oh
you think mr. shingles and mr. psoriasis
just go away
Oh bro come on mister that's right this
goes do you think she goes
i'ma hang back hey come on man back to
the tall grass yeah yeah just waiting
it's just one's your special droppin
soon all right you do your thing I'll
come I'll come next week yeah I'm gonna
stop by next to my specialist out right
now
by next week complicated Apes on 20
different platforms including iTunes and
YouTube yeah here's the people keep a Z
if you don't know where to get a special
suck a dick bro and get shingles it's
everywhere it's everywhere
just just go ahead and get just do some
how are your names
just [ __ ] for you it's on every
platform yeah it's everywhere yeah so
find it yeah you shin hwal [ __ ] and
thanks for down eyes it's been doing
well so thank you for that yeah so some
eyes come on you're done by the way oh
yeah
and I took I'm taking they they gave me
valtrex which you get for herpes yep so
I have to go pick up a vowel tricks but
they gave me some at the hospital
already feeling better already way
better but I got to go now the pharmacy
and go I'll take my herpes medication
please my they don't know if it's for of
course they dick or leg too much for my
dick is anything worse when you pick up
weird medication and it's off hot
pharmacist or when you have to pick up
for have you ever had a pharmacist who's
a fan I sure have a friend he goes bro
yeah let's do dude I can't buy a vehicle
uh can you uh oh yeah prescription there
and they can give it to you like oh the
doctor last night cuz you remind me of
the guy from Sex in the City I go well
that might be because I am and then that
set that set off the whole way to marry
you and then your answer um so what
presto did was yesterday today the first
day yesterday had pressed did Rich Eisen
shoutout to Rich Eisen love that Rich
Eisen favorite guy grant as far as
professional sports go media him a Dan
Patrick but Rich Eisen beats amount so
glossy so good the best well get Marty
factors to just got done did he talk
about he just got done with the NFL
Combine when he runs the 40 and raises
awareness and money for autism I didn't
know he ran the 40 yeah yeah he does as
a joke but you donate money and then you
you take you film you you running 40
things you donate money look at him he's
got good form
not really he ran like a seven flat
anyway
one of the best guys in all the
batteries amazed my favorite any
hilarious great well good get on that
we'll get him up on a salir I talked to
him about I [ __ ] love that guy yeah
so you did Rich Eisen today yeah we
don't saying again WTF you got serious I
had to cancel that you have what the
[ __ ] with man yeah now what do i five
five o'clock in Silver Lake Glendale
well it'll be cool drive though now like
that because I don't have hey Martin
let's not do five o'clock well I had
tubes out on you were here I had to push
it was supposed to be four I had to push
it too far even for ya God that stuff to
our interview yeah it'll be it'll be
what it is but at the end of the day a
fake bro the traffic's crazy you're
supposed to do serious I don't have the
juice in my Tesla Tesla for sure get
more [ __ ] superchargers until you get
a geek are you gay results bro you might
be right yeah get car gay results yeah
why you gotta be a homophobe about I'm
not losing gays and just kind of Gaius
no I guess them yeah the same way Brits
use the word [ __ ] yeah mmm dicey [ __ ] is
usually a cigarette that's what I'm
saying oh yeah Kevin do you have a
family [ __ ] I grew up with that Jim may
say that yeah you did yeah it mama's
English correct dude um so you're gonna
run out of juice so I can make it don't
ask we've a ride way too busy but we'll
figure now I had to pick you up right
get work Eber yeah well my Porsche yeah
you're talking about the lemon I had
yeah the highway on the 4 or 5 had to
come pick brining up my [ __ ] lipstick
orange GTS yeah well that was a mistake
by the engineers on the on the engine
they [ __ ] up gt3 has no problem how
about the Comedy Store the you know I
pull in last night and when I pull in
those the door guys go thank God he and
drive the truck I'm like is it that big
of a problem like we should got a plan
for it man it's just it kind of stressed
everyone out I'm like dude I will never
drive that thing here I had no idea like
you should have to plan for it cuz yeah
we can't really turn and we've cut I'm
like I'll say no more I will never bring
that's a child never yeah it's like it's
my daily driver now when I yeah I Drive
it everyday
why is that Erickson s class of trucks
so it's like it's so comfy and I got my
all you got everything going on there's
no effort no it's great super safe
what I like it it's not the truck for
you no you know you stay that test why
do you say that because remember I said
gay Tesla gave results
yeah there's reason why your why you
gravitate towards the Terry's Nikola
Tesla it's not for our shingle ridden
52-year well there's no one with
shingles it would drive them Fords bro
it's not Raptors I summon I get
sensitive skin the Rattlers not for me
yeah that big deal dude but how about
speaking of people dying my Barbara
right I used to have that joke where I
made about hey soos yeah it's on my
flashlight comes out he died I go in and
get my hair cut today again I have this
joke it's in mine is my stress right
time out how you I've got the same
haircut from this same guy for last
[ __ ] seven years I'm Adele a it's a
big that's the best Lincoln barbers off
Lincoln Venice California I go there
every Tuesday to get my hair cut every
[ __ ] Tuesday and I went today since I
moved from where I currently live so I
live farther away so I can't go as often
and I'm growing my hair like barely
Gruber would get to that so I haven't
been as much right I know sexy have it
best sexy dead sexy I've been as much if
shingles so when I got there you know I
was hoping I knew he had a heart attack
but I figured to come back from it
so then I'd see a lousy excuse me no 48
yeah
now I'm 46 three kids and a wife denied
there's a picture I posted on my
Instagram chin that I go look everybody
it's Tom Seguros brother Mexican brother
and I [ __ ] going today passed away
dude they had pictures all over the I'm
like no way made me super sad man that's
really super sad it's all sad there's
families yeah I keep going I really tom
was not pleased I said he looks like
this guy at all yeah I just did Tom's
your mom's house and they were not they
Christina and him did not appreciate
that I'll say they're kind of joking me
tell they weren't happy about it but
yeah it's [ __ ] I can't believe it and
I go what happened they said just had a
heart attack and then it's brain never
responded and then they called the
Widowmaker a lot a lot of guys when you
get to be I had a member
cardiologist Ted until I know you'll
lose friends between the age of 45 and
55 do you check because that please view
you can have a compromise near a hora or
whatever it's called the Widowmaker and
Deegan Isis guys and I'm telling the
best barber the best barber I've ever
had
I can't believe pass through it yeah
yeah you can tell they're all pretty
shook from it like just cheered they'd
leave you know it's like what a bummer
what about them well we could see him
here at least right there he is that's
him what a great guy look at them and
they do they're not happy no how can you
be happy man
well I'm saying Tom and Chris you don't
have did you that don't look so good at
all am I crazy I'm a Mike [ __ ] crazy
look they're both human so you can see
that there is a resemblance there they
is there no similar human they're not
similar at all not even even just like
guys Wow yeah just maybe just a beard
they're both humans and males Wow every
every day since I walk down with God
every month it's a girl Wow
I think they sound similar to so I think
maybe because you don't know him yeah
like they have similar vibes so I'm
finally post of that tag Tom he they not
crazy happy about that no really
but whatever yeah well and so on his
show he showed a bunch of kids with Down
syndrome said this who we think you look
like no all right interesting
yeah all right interesting yeah so shout
out to them terrible story about that
barber though yeah bummer right shingles
death a lot of stuff going on on a
Wednesday I know dude I know man I know
bro not my Tess I know bro sue for me
poor me I can't charge my Tesla I have
so many problems you do have a lot of
problems um dude I took a little shot of
Johnny Walker last night it's just a
nice shot dry Walker
one beer I felt loose bro you don't lose
when you you think that's my yeah formed
at the economy store yes my routine I
think from now on that's how shots
nice little beer no no now take this now
take this clip fast forward a year from
now okay
Brendan's not showing up yeah Brendan's
dead bro
he's grew his hair out run everywhere
Bryan Callen no it's not good now here's
a girl now yep I'm Venice Beach doing
this Lots that could happen and then you
rob me you just robbed me
you just know not be like yeah be like
guy who hustle dude like dude you know
I'm good for it man just give me two
grand an apple two and then we'll figure
out bro they called the other day I need
six how crazy as I haven't heard from
that guy how crazy is really yeah yeah
no [ __ ] he's fast dude surprising sucks
man
yeah why did the power plant got money
out of me yeah he's fine we had the
powerful jo koy on the show today
yeah where's here in my faves to be here
at 1:10 he said all right nice one tan
he's come from sorry are you excited to
Marin are you gonna call him out tell me
hey my friend Brendan Schaub says you
hate him okay do that all right he
doesn't like me cuz I'm a former jock
was that what you heard
yeah yeah suppose to be on the show and
then just come in just coming in the
middle of the episode in Billiam it's
his house yeah it's in his garage how
about that guy kill he kills it though
yeah he's a great inner is a great
interviewer and we had the president on
yeah yeah Marquis you talked to him
about that
no I'll see how the Secret Service came
excuse me a week early put snipers on
top of all the houses and shut off the
road yeah they talked about every time a
president moves they say it costs like a
million dollars just to move one from
point do you think if your Trump thing
how hard is to [ __ ] your side pieces
feel creative yes do that
excuse me you think you still do oh my
Oh what like three how the what real
[ __ ] next time hole dude they did their
theme in the secret server to think well
you they're the [ __ ] commander of the
free world man but so they're go hey
guess what you [ __ ] CI Special Service
[ __ ] here's the thing yeah el honcho
here likes a busload
yes you guys gonna shut your [ __ ]
mouth otherwise on the throw employees
did that will I bus nuts underground but
when Clinton was governor he did that of
course but but and and when is president
bro
got his dick sucked in the over lives
but I'd be harder with all those people
watching every move you make no not with
Secret Service because they and they
sign non-disclosure so they can't tell
anyone
Kathleen McKinley is out her name
whatever she said that when she came to
Clinton for ask for help for her husband
he was holding the tray he gave her the
tray and she held the tray and he
started feeling her tits right there oh
yeah and she was like good old boy
he's just feeling my he's attacking me
here yeah and III feel like I'm going to
I'm basically gonna spill everything and
my mother goes you know why I believe
her I go why cuz because that's exactly
what a woman would say and and thinking
that in that instance like you're gonna
spill everything yeah I don't know about
that her I don't know I'll tell you what
though the I'll tell you what though
about Bill Clinton though his side
pieces were not hot he's just like it's
too hard out here in the streets let me
just help in and write what they were
buxom women he like likes you like the
big bucks like the big mouths on a girl
a buxom yet the buxom buxom bu x om
means robust yeah curved line yeah yeah
he like some robust yeah no I just think
he likes whatever whatever came his way
he's a spider here's a web a dick web
and if you film that web he was a
pounding yeah uh that one would she's
gotten oh my god come out the original
dick knows she don't who [ __ ] up
everything way to go come on please take
that back don't say that please I'm just
saying bro
that's Paula Jones right yeah she [ __ ]
it all up for everybody well I think she
got dragged into it though didn't she
now you're seeing that dude you know he
oh you don't know about this no you know
Elizabeth Hurley flew to the White House
several times
oh the rumors she was sucking him off
well no [ __ ] she's one of the hottest
women on the plan yeah and he's the most
powerful man what's wrong with that what
do you think there oh you think she was
given him [ __ ] it's my son she's warm
he's still so hot oh she's one of the
hottest ever ever oh and again an
actress and that acts about Elizabeth
Hurley for stood
I claims that her and Bill Clinton
hooked up dude you don't hang out with
old Billy boy and just [ __ ] share a
drink you kidding no team to the White
House I would love I would I would he
absent that did that would be the whole
reason to be oppressed has there ever
been a single president no like a single
president like I'll just player not that
I know dude imagine if a single
president was in the White House and he
just [ __ ] she's just 53 she look what
could they do Frank Grillo of women look
what easy cable hey what could they do
what could they possibly do let's say
let's say your cheese's crime and ijen
good for you
Wow she's looking for attention woman
stops god I feel like kicking somebody
right now dick she's just really
gorgeous she's gorgeous top ten bro
[ __ ] English bro a [ __ ] man
top ten oh [ __ ] I feel like doing
jujitsu right now I'm giving you my
shingles I played I like to see it with
the makeup off but I want to rub my
[ __ ] pustules on your face right now
pustule you tell me your shingles yeah
I'm talking about my shingles mm
apparently I have to stay away from
three small in who's the [ __ ] yellow
bastard on the table he's a jockey he's
at he's aa rider god yeah he he's a
jockey Jesus Christ he's gonna the back
line when God said I'm getting out good
looks
hey in the back come on man
you never know long guy in the back
maybe it's just the angle in the back uh
Amy angle so you know sucks way more
than root fighters as jockeys they gotta
suck weight a lot of drugs and a lot of
weight sucking I know you know what
though who gives a [ __ ]
Oh cuz you're riding another animal sir
sir look at me are you light on light do
you know how much money is involved in
horse racing don't you know the money
you know you want a horse up top I know
your way you know I fly crazy I know
that's fantastic does it mean [ __ ] about
racehorses yeah jock horses there's a
ton of jockeys you need their specific
jockeys that are winning you gotta have
the right jockey because there are
certain weight and everything don't [ __ ]
around about you don't know enough about
definitely know about it still don't
ever don't
speak about it I don't like that how
you're treating it with a lack of oxygen
I need respect it's a complete joke what
yeah
what is if you're small guy like you're
maybe just an inch above a jockey or
like a lightweight fighter no so I'm not
offensive yeah there were there before -
no you could be a job there five four
one one fifteen know you could be a
jockey sir you'd have to lose some
weight B could be a job no I could not
I'm too robust oh yeah I'm waiting -
awesome
no I'm not do you see if you're born the
size of a jockey what occupations can
you really are very small people but
they have to suck weight and there's a
lot of drugs and there they're Cowboys -
they're on drugs they're Cowboys there's
a lot of stuff that goes on in a horse
world dude which you don't know in those
stupid horses everyone knows that no no
the apple with the jockeys yeah it's a
it's a very corrupt world - it's the
sport of kings
I don't know with the Ambler know this
you know this but the job hundreds of
millions of dollars with criminals kings
everybody's everybody's involved in
horse racing dude Arab sheiks you don't
understand no I know horse races I'm
saying you're saying the jockeys are on
drugs or the horse there's a lot of
drugs who among jockeys why cocaine
because they hate their lives they try
to the media trying several look how
small they are they they're really tight
but if you say it one more time I'm
gonna wait to my singles up oh dude
please don't touch with your shingles
okay so contagious it's not actually for
Ana chin yeah
Google shingles contagious so infants
very old people so don't hang with
newborns or old people or not befriend
you'll be fine because you have shank
viruses spread through direct contact
with fluid from the wrasse blizzard
caused by shingles once the rafts has
developed crossed the person no longer
infectious yours doesn't look crusty she
was less contagious than chickenpox and
the risk a person with she'll spread the
virus is low if it's covered but if not
will spread like wildfire okay it
doesn't say that's right it does think
you're added that now we're dying your
pork ass my shingles kid ladies and
gentlemen you can get shingles in the
mouth I don't know probably you can get
it everywhere oh look at how short those
guys are don't ever say that I'm look at
how tiny they are
then you could be a jockey and you know
this by tower over those girls I'm a
tall guy you've the same size as the
girl in the blue no I'm not I'm a tall
I wow yeah jockeys a weird world huh
do they stunt their growth no it's just
they're short people and they live
around horses and like everything else
Wow we get so small little black one
yeah hold on is he not black right
is he not african-american news black is
also easy small all you said was nothing
racist or I can say look at the little
white one and we don't know who I'm
talking about because they're all white
and little yeah Jin Zhu min on him easy
and no one with more melanin in this
skin no that's a black dudes back and
he's time only guy next to his black 2
is mulatto mix-a-lot
they're both small black here's here's
something I'm just spitballing ideas
here I know horse rates in mid around
forever why have two more [ __ ] riders
uh because what I feel is they're so
strong I don't know I'm white yeah
matter cuz you have to be athletic
oh wow you went there huh about you real
now cuz you have to be up in your
stirrups and you a move at the horse and
the main thing you have to do is not be
in the horses way so you have to have an
insane sass shut up though bro shut up
bring up or Jord midgets Kindle jockey
riding in slow motion and watch how oh
my god I'm or or if you have a noose and
guy is a [ __ ]
alright dwarf or whatever the word
little people though that I think
they're just images of people dressing
up an odd strip it has to be a reason
why they don't put them on there you
gotta be a really excellent we said
jockey right riding horse yeah and slow
motion yeah well there's a video Brian
on KTLA we're right there dude is it
today
I know for Kern event you got that [ __ ]
from full house getting arrested yeah
yeah I know it first let's get to that
we get to with you at all slow motion
one first yeah
[Applause]
now they're not athletic though you're
hanging onto the haunted course we just
going down to me there's so much to look
at this
oh my god dude look at a mag on 45 miles
an hour well see how close he is you
have to get hanging right on the horse
do everything J like this on a horse
suck arms out
you know what drove you've been hanging
around the [ __ ] and you're up in your
stirrups the whole time brah ho little
bikes have to be crazy strong yeah
notice you or not make one little
mistake oh not a sport you know I'm
saying not one little mistake not a
sport it is a sport that's home the
horses though yeah it might be a skill
over a sport this is the age-old debate
right Golf a sport or a skill skill
let's go
so that looks amazing please turn this
off Jim before I shoot myself in the
face yeah it's more about getting out of
the way of the horse so that would be a
skill oh no I dispute the KTLA stuff how
is it those morning shows always
interesting
they are always interesting they're just
out of touch they're little later here
we are with Bryan Callen right I loved
you on Entourage oh well I wasn't on
their little class they're just they're
going through the motions it's amazing I
don't do press anyway you know a new
person as far as like to go when I'm on
the road like hey can you come on KTLA
and talk about and like absolutely not
that does not help I think just do
podcasts you know you're your own
publicist now through social media and
your friends and our network of friends
100% they're just so out there they have
no idea what the [ __ ] watch Bryan Callen
on his new stand that's good that's the
channel that's the show that I watched
the mostly the local one channel 5 it's
the best one Bryan Callen suggests that
men are complicated apes and you take on
amongst others dads who drive minivans
who should be taking on yeah
we are complicated and I think we're
treating each other like mounds so I'm
kind of tight you know we use these
words that don't mean anything when you
talk about somebody you like white black
Latino Asian 48 countries in Asia but
you know we mean so I'm kind of making
an argument for the fact that we are
basically we cover those cute that
Sergio nice though huh
yeah you got hang glider's hanging up I
don't do uh you know the public debate
in the public square is a very cruel
place you get caught doing one thing
wrong and every
all of us have at least 10 thoughts it
broke make me laugh though huh it's
fired well oh I'm sorry you a professor
no I mean I've had fights with my wife
where you would have called Homeland
Security I'm a bad guy I was just having
a moment and we need to start treating
people that way so it's but the whole
the whole thing is kind of an argument
to be a little more forgiving and just a
little like I'm having a moment that can
be sum it up thank God I'm having a
moment I don't want to be the same
person and you know public or at work as
I am in bed be boring I want to get my
mind this I use it as a proper fake
drink my water I'm sure I've seen Brian
perform several times even you make
audiences laugh you've got some action
you make audiences like just a second
but can I just about your podcast the
fighter and the kid the fighter indicate
is basically a podcast where Brendan
Schaub who is a UFC heavyweight was
really really funny and I said why don't
we do a podcast together because I
always hang out with Joe Rogan and who's
a dear friend and he was just making us
laugh this fighter this giant fighter is
killing us so we started doing a podcast
and it's basically a comedian and a cage
fighter and we both get paid for what we
got in trouble for our whole life you're
talking about a guy who punches people
in the face for a living I talk like I'm
still fighting back that's an issue
million 10 million downloads yeah it's
nuts I had no idea be this big no idea
so I guess I'm talented right was the or
that was the origin shares yeah you seem
a little tight are you scaredy well
around him I produce estrogen he's a
giant marry a handsome man - there he is
Brides making us watch a interview on
himself yeah let's get you say just just
in time right you're doing pressings
late guess watches it I was actually
thank God
hey I gotta get the old guys done though
huh yeah and also when they bring me up
don't go use a fighter you all right hi
papa how are ya
what's up brother what's up man glad
you're here I'm good thank you for your
lovely kicks love the outlaw thank you
those Gucci kicks man yeah make me some
money
well I've been doing that
since day one white yeah yeah yeah you
look good rich at first a little hood
rich yep I'm just giving over that yeah
yeah spend it before I had it you know
Nordstrom Rack are you not good my head
Neiman Marcus Lisa I spent more than you
always always did I'm the same way I'm
the worst when I wasn't when I was uh
when I was coming up I'd work at
Nordstrom Rack and I worked at Borders
Books and literally spend my paychecks
on a Gucci [ __ ] at Nordstrom's rack oh
yeah
there's pictures of me like like in a
newspaper I got a picture we're in a
Gucci bucket had and I remember like
spending my whole paycheck that I made
it Mirage I was working at the Mirage
just for that that Gucci bucket hat you
know what's interesting how you know
it's like Gucci like it's it's like the
hottest thing right the hottest brand
it's like it's crossed over and they're
like pop culture and rap mmm now Gucci
and lot of those brands have come out
like anti like urban like they've been
stuff and they don't want them that the
products really not for the urban lower
class Society they don't want them
haven't we were just yesterday I love
that you're saying that it's kind of
like they don't like rappers with the
name Gucci Mane they hate it they don't
want they think it the product even
though they have literally brought their
sales up through the roof did you know
they did so it's like all these fashion
houses like there's a main fashion house
that owns like Gucci YSL all all under
the same baby searches yeah there's what
I'm swayed into a fashion so there's one
like house and there's all these brands
that branch off of it so the mess with
the pricing and releases of all the
things but everyone they're making the
same they're making the same makeup they
don't make money off their shoes and
clothes for that actually it's a loss
for them they make money off their
perfumes and everything bag Xander yeah
the cheap [ __ ] you have the cheap yeah
that's just like a side hustle yeah I
could see that because the shoes are
yeah these are nothing as far as profit
but that bag is [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] that's better are you kidding
that pot most that costs them like 10
bucks for that back hey $3500 for the
low I and that level Hermes bag and it's
a 300 be tough that's
yeah I'm talking about amazing you're
amazing 500 be tough - that's why I know
nobody knows damn it I'm addicted you
are yeah I have a lot I have a lot just
stop by a buyer by the consumer dude why
look that's how this Wyatt is why this
is why I have an addiction to it I don't
I don't do drugs
I don't do I don't drink yeah and one
thing I've always been into is fashion
I've always I always loved buying the
nice things so that's okay my diction
like Jordans anything I used to work at
a finish line and I remember putting
Jordan fours on layaway and like every
paycheck I was putting yeah but I want
to know that psychologic ecology behind
it because I know a woman who spends her
husband buys her really expensive stuff
because she grew up poor so and it was
humiliating for her so when she shows up
in a Gucci bag and really nice clothing
she's treated differently by the saying
so when you grow up poor that can be
humiliating so you want nice [ __ ] yeah
what do you think it was about you that
that caused you to I was broke yeah yeah
I was broke too
so I see was that status thing I think
it's just like I think it's that like
when you come in I don't think well you
know I'm successful but I'm like well
thank God he put himself together
ya know like yeah I know I don't think
of that it's almost like a language so
unique like I can talk to him about
these a dope outfit mmm got the roll you
just like fashion for the I know but
it's but it's not because I don't like
it because I know because I because we
know Jo success when he has money that's
not what I like and I don't know what it
is I don't know I just like things I
don't know what it is either
it's like Kanye's lying when he says uh
I spent it before I had it yeah I mean
what is that per se see like do you do
you not to say it right yeah but he's
got to wear it I don't know that's
that's all an acting teacher who used to
say that to his students he'd go I think
you should buy the Ferrari before you
can afford it I just think it's a good
motivator it is like yeah
is if you believe in yourself do it
there's a book out there says Dress for
Success you don't mean like the create a
mean it like Rogaine was like that Robin
used to always spend money and wouldn't
save a lot and I was like what are you
doing he'd be like I have confidence in
myself
yeah that's back in the day Eliot
Rogen's again if you're gonna whenever I
do like a major purchase something I
usually go and talk to Rogan about it
and he's always like you just get
started you get it you just getting
started it's not me [ __ ] he was the
house you buy now you're gonna laugh at
in five years
yeah but Jesus dude is get it trust me I
did it anyone that talks themselves out
of stuff you just continually talk
yourself out of [ __ ] but there are
always they're stupid people right like
I think there's a fine line and the
reason why there's a fine lines because
I think a lot of people fall in the trap
they see like rappers that [ __ ] up or
like or athletes athletes rappers or
actor who made one sitcom and bought a
place in the [ __ ] palisade yeah but
they only had that you know actin is up
and down what we do there's longevity
it's an animal but you also have to be
smart with your success right that's
what you're saying there's people that
are stupid they get a bunch of money and
blow it correct but there's also people
that are like we can find money but we
also know how to continue making that
money correct well so they're people
turn their money into money and also
there is something to be said about
saving money I mean exactly
all kind of sure and and being long-term
investing your money and that's why I
own a restaurant boy where's my camera
that's and that's why I own a restaurant
in Vegas right your sister runs right
Joe yeah just stop yeah not a time for
you to I'm just trying to get you a
Rolex but what am i what are you doing
it's a fake laugh if you're doing a high
I'm successful and so is he
not so much hey what the [ __ ] Joe just
saying this is my play sure and you're
showing up a news clip wearing my
sweatshirt you're trying to promote your
brand with my
just workout
that's a [ __ ] news that's cashmere
sweater yes that's a [ __ ] Russell
Athletic Center from dick take it back -
I'm not taking it back right now get it
you can't even fix that in the color
code what are you trying to adjust the
color [ __ ] gray
[ __ ] you a [ __ ] great what's not great
tix brings out my eyes you don't have a
success Rome stands oh what's your
[ __ ] restaurant so I can not go
dropped it's a registred joke yeah it's
a mister what do I serve you - P -
Philippine no I so it's Japanese it's
jabu jabu and you're a but your sister
runs it for you my sister runs it that's
Joe so does my dad she's amazing without
her I'd be [ __ ] yo J yo J shabu-shabu
[ __ ] oh there it is yeah in Vegas yeah
that looks kinda where as it wears it
and baby believe that uh it's right I
got it I got a house out there it's
right by my mom's house in my house brag
no Brad what's between my mom's house
and I have another house out there and
then the restaurants to the right
Wow sorry you're bragging that I have a
house out there that's paid off and I
bought my mom's wait why did you say huh
no I paid off I bought it okay - I know
keeping at least their houses or make
payments I bought okay I bought my mom's
all right you doesn't have to worry
about it she's living a nice life okay
you're doing with my camera it's my mom
doesn't have to worry about bills
supposed to talk to us this is you've
changed so much since you got Hey
it's your turn yeah you give that drink
oh yeah yes
hey how about what I wanna do Cho hey
baby how about when I want in Sean Witt
dude I thought we were talking about
something I said selling out the will
Brown wait sold out the we were like six
times it's pregnant how many was it no
he said you sort out the Wilber uh no no
you talked about Hawaii you're like yeah
any so you sold out Hawaii like eight
times I go it was 11
yellow chip it was 11 is elected Oh 11
but who's counting who's counting but
who's counting
you have blown up dude it's been fun and
I and I think a lot of it was and by the
way I'm did this is all fun ok dude I
mean trust us the van service this is
what we do yeah I really do you I
remember you and I man I remember like
at the Laugh Factory and then you would
walk in how long my oh man
well no no longer man - all right go
[ __ ] yourself hey all right what do you
talking about what are you talking about
I'm just spitballing Mariano yes but no
we have time frame time frame so you
referenced what what is that a tease
what a tease say no yeah was that it was
in the in the 2000s yeah walking so you
found out well oh yeah all right has
anyone called you this a son of a [ __ ]
yes how many of Tom's so this is mm
really mm but I just used to I used to
love watching this guy man I just you
you'd walk in you're like a Wednesday
night cuz I was doing every night at the
Laugh Factory
Jamie was my manager and then he would
walk in and I would just literally like
[ __ ] this guy's talking about nothing
[ __ ] nothing and crushing yeah
rushing you did this one thing about
just standing he goes would it be great
if you just stand like this all day
what are you doing I'm standing and you
did that for like five minutes that was
this set but that I love that that's
what I love about about us we learn from
each other and then and your confidence
and your ability to just be like I'm
just going to talk about this and I
don't give a [ __ ] where it goes and and
that's when I say I've taken that from
you that ability to just like talk and
just whatever it is that's on my mind
just say it and if find funny comes out
of it the funny can I like that I made
you and he did not make me know but what
I learned from you is to not do it you
know I like that I molded you and and
they didn't hold me at all right if I
did I broke it
because it was it was him then
crystalline or do you listen what I mean
is I like that you were in the nest I
was feeding my with some know and then I
lay down and night when you grew
feathers I released you and that's what
I know that not where's my camera
there's only one camera by the way like
it worth like oh you're talking it's a
podcast I understand it just know that
if I want to shoot you out of the sky
they won't happen dude look oh wow thank
God for him huh what you don't mean what
are you doing listening to the kid right
if you really think about it your turn
if you really think about it if this
splits the show split yeah no one's
listening to the [ __ ] it okay dude
that's about what 5% of the [ __ ]
hey you don't know that you know I have
metrics watch what happens I have
analytics where do you get those I know
someone here what's his name Korean guy
Koreans no other [ __ ] I'm just saying
Koreans a good complain shins Korea
where's my camera to all my Korean
people you know you're not going ethics
but no seriously they're already
thinking about the fighter pod does that
even that even flows good divider okay
you point the kid what who old news bro
what can't even sell shirts you know he
and I used to do and before anything
happened for us
I'd be like we try to out success each
other you and Jose bought a [ __ ] I
thought of a man it was the word when
you have a house a lot of rooms a
mansion I know I can't find one with a
helicopter pad and we just go back and
forth tops to Joe for you how long did
it take before he started booming and as
far as staying up to that like last
night I was talking some of the door
guys and we're talking about Jim Carrey
and they're like dude you know he was a
door guy for eight years that comes for
before anything broke for him though I
get eight years
use only Jim Jimmy Larry eight years
David I remembers parking cars to the
comedy store Jim eight years when I got
the Tonight Show I was 14 years in and
what age is this just so I was like
thirty I was 34 when I got the time
yeah yeah and then uh and then I was
working at Nordstrom Rack but that's
also when the Tonight Show meant
something different time waiter at Four
Seasons for nine years all the time I
knew oh that's right at the Laugh actor
I remember that he would go up I still
have like a waiter outfit on he'd had
the white button-up and black that's
what I that's when I see that kind of
success for you and for for Sebastien
and stuff like that yeah it is it's so
well earned like you did the amount of
time you spent in those trenches you
know and doing that [ __ ] and I remember
when I think you got a Netflix special
and people saw how funny you were doing
it wrong didn't do his research wrong so
wrong he said no to me no I know I know
they did but then they cut then they
bought it and then everything exploded
as I shot it right and that you should
say that tell that story Joe no but I
remember that did you know though what
happened here no I do they said go said
no to me they said no to me we're like
two years yeah and then finally so we're
did but we're so all I'm to go back what
you're how many specials do you have I
had I had two and a half if he consider
my wait half-hour that counts comedy
still you have two and a half and where
were those other two an end they were
all on Comedy Central okay Kerry yeah so
two and a half special June a specials
and then it was four years before County
Central offered again and I turned down
because I wanted Netflix and I can't
pursue a Netflix and pursuing him I'm
offering to fly him out like just come
see me come see the routine showcase
well yeah I was trying to showcase for
him and then uh and they said no finally
like they were like you know what we're
just gonna go ahead and pass like you
know wonder you know I don't know why
and I know in no way am I offended by it
you know what I mean like they had their
decisions and that's fine
it made me hungrier and I'm glad they
said no cuz I just I took my money and I
shot it myself and uh where I shot in
Seattle and I took I wore every single
hat man I was III the the promoter I
rented up the theater I got the lighting
guy the director the producer and I let
you do though Joe came from yeah
like they were gonna go to me and then I
was gonna show this day like I want to
make a product where they would be like
oh yeah that's a Netflix product yeah
like I could have went and shot it on a
budget but then would they have bought
it no you know I don't know like I don't
know what the answer is but I knew that
if they're gonna say no well then I'm
gonna shoot my own Netflix special and
you felt I'm going to show them why they
should have said you and you felt like
you had to be on Netflix cuz I feel like
you're at a level where you can you
don't have to be absolute shopping or
that not before that yeah a Netflix
special that where where you went from
like plan you know clubs some theaters
but then when they saw how good you sell
it no Chelsea Lately I know that you
were selling really well but what I'm
saying is that when Netflix when people
who didn't know you saw you with that
algorithm yeah boom it was over yeah
many but but again it's because you're
so funny they just more people need to
see that but my friend Joe is the don't
don't you think let's say Netflix never
happened you I think you would still be
right where you're at
oh yeah I hate to tell you I think
Netflix is great and they're you know
they're great at what they do but if you
would uh because the your hustler ways
which start when you're young Vegas put
on the shows put out [ __ ] flyers
hustling the Orange County doing all
that you would have figured out and
released that material thank you because
I was it might got out no matter what in
my head when I was onstage like
performing that night even though in my
head I was like oh [ __ ] Netflix already
said no but I'm still trying to be funny
yeah but I swear to God because we taped
two shows at night in between shows I
remember looking at my whole team and I
was just like I'm gonna give a [ __ ] I
will sell this out of the back of my car
like hammer did you like hammer would
sell CDs out of the back of his car yeah
I was like I will do that I will make I
will recoup this money like I wasn't sad
about it but I knew I had to do it
what's weird is cuz uh maybe to
reflection on myself if if I would have
went to Netflix and they said no I went
I'd [ __ ] them watch this and then blown
it up elsewhere just to prove them wrong
yeah I mean that's that's that's the
road you could you could take you know
there's no wrong decision but although
the fact is that that Netflix is still
got that market share it still has that
algorithm and if you get in
good position on Netflix you are going
to reach a lot of people fast I will say
this though you too here's why here's
where I'm gonna argue with even more
than athletes
you still need to put out a good product
of course you still have not a weird
ends I don't want anyone to think like
oh I just need to shoot my special and
give it to still need to make good
product oh there's a humming special on
a Netflix so much awful and ask those
comics how's he going on the road pin
even though they have a special on
Netflix it didn't work that's not the
end-all be-all yeah yes that [ __ ] haha
it was crazy
it changed my life but Netflix did yeah
well not had an when that special
dropped on Netflix it was it was it was
done it was it thank God it was like
that yes it was [ __ ] when I back down
the road it was just like everything was
sold out for the whole year like
Australia where adding shows Singapore
Malaysia
that's amazing worldwide Germany yeah
everything everything sold out like we
couldn't even we had to add shows this
is crazy Hawaii you sold [ __ ] yeah
why we did the arena we sold four arenas
out Jesus shot then shot another Netflix
special and by the way I'm not I love
Netflix thank you for saying no to me
because sometimes you need that maybe I
wouldn't have been as angry maybe I
wouldn't have performed as hard that
night I had something to prove but I
think it says something about you cuz a
lot of guys have been like [ __ ] Netflix
and then got down themselves then maybe
the special didn't wouldn't go as well
yeah or you get super bitter you're
making fun of other comics who do have
success yeah that's that's what I see
it's stupid doesn't help you know it
does it but also you being on Netflix
doesn't that that's not like Allan's on
Netflix what comics don't get because
you guys special on Netflix doesn't mean
I'm not gonna get yeah okay that's
nothing to do with it we all have our
own plat pass we all have our own Road
our own journey it's like don't worry
about as long as you're focused on
whatever it is you want you're gonna get
up you're gonna end up there yeah you go
sidetrack and go Roget start driving on
the gravel that bumpy [ __ ] on the road
that gets you nowhere just carpet and
[ __ ] b- yeah yeah keep riding hop you
know you hit a nail [ __ ] just slows down
you know who and your [ __ ] you know
Andrew Schultz's yeah I love it
vomit from
your kite he's on Rogen tomorrow yeah
he's on rollin tomorrow he was just he
did mine yep he did ours right he's out
here doing la tour he's back on roaming
tomorrow yeah he his special funny by
the way
top time for me right now yeah he so far
he didn't get picked up by netflix or
showtime or anyone went very cool watch
this and then just started changing the
game and briefs and clips of his special
in clips and segments and then this like
sick to my musics different segments and
then finally it comes out you watch all
of it but not the hour all at once
different segments and each segment get
over a million views yeah can you play
on that right now and now what happens
now if you hear yeah I listen to show
the flagrant two and brilliant idiots
yeah how all shows are sold out yeah
listen what we're trying to see is we're
not [ __ ] on Netflix I'm glad that
flicks did that to me it made me work
harder I love Netflix they've changed my
life I got two more specials that I'm
about to drop I love my flights yeah
well what we're trying to say is don't
let anyone deter you from whatever it is
that you're trying to do who's that
stayed on that [ __ ] grind and always
stay focused you're gonna make it well I
think the the message is Netflix is in
the end all be all
there's a comic you can there's you some
of the end results Tommy Central
Showtime HBO you do it yourself just on
YouTube
yeah there's iTunes there's for so many
different platforms yeah Brian right
like this pod is [ __ ] amazing like it
changed your life yes and and you know
and I'm happy for him because for years
nothing was happening for him hey
where's now know that lots of things
hangover yeah nothing happened I think
you're a man yeah I was on man no one
even knew no good it gave up man that's
the message we're trying to say I don't
think that somebody's
it happened 65 I'm Sophie to [ __ ] this
is 65 this podcast a Sarah boy you don't
know that 60 60 I like I would have want
to kill myself 60 like not what am I
doing with my life
that's not my it's a bad if you wanna
end it all that's how I stop calling
myself the kid that's a have an old man
wearing hip clothes I'll [ __ ] talk
like that jo koy take it back what are
you doing right now
I saw this episode of him take it a
shirt off in boxing you can roll the
tits no I don't you have old got a great
old take it back up
he had old man buff no I don't [ __ ] I'm
not that snot what this is about we're
about let me put these I don't feel like
those are even real glass they aren't
those who makes the Tom Ford I'm my
fortune on those huh
there was a $800 glasses yeah just for
the frame look Saint Laurent jeans yes
you shame bro I'm not different you are
you're some wrenches you're like you're
not even seeing me your eyes are glass
Tovar I'm looking at no I haven't looked
me in the eye once I'm just a guy kid
yeah I feel like I feel like I would
like Jo twice not like my stock with the
fries why are you laughing
you are joking right I love you know
we're reaching for he's getting ready
for your special jo did you you didn't
do sets like at the store or the Laugh
Factory no no I went to weird places
yeah yeah I went to coffee houses is
that what - I just wanted to work out
stuff yeah uh and wait you're talking
about when I did Corbin when I when I
did like my TV set that's when I wanted
4-minute set yeah cuz I didn't do a TV
sitting a while and uh I wonder they're
hard four minutes is hard and I want to
put myself in weird spots yeah so I was
I was going around like Lankershim there
was like a weed house that was doing
stand-up I was going like like the front
you know The Improv the
but myself in like environments were
like I didn't have my audience you know
where I love those I love those
environment last night perfect literally
an alleyway and I went is this the gig
and it was I walk in it's an old hair
salon basically a room and then anamoly
could be it's in Culver City and I walk
up on stage and I'm surrounded by there
people sitting on either side of me so
I'm surrounded by people it's like
theater-in-the-round or something / this
shitty curtain in front of me it was so
much fun it was what it was it brings me
back to New York that's those the kind
of gigs I did yeah I did 1000 of those
gigs yeah you did wherever you could
Eddie when you get up on these in these
coffee shop people are talking back
there bars don't Davidoff and I did a
show on time he goes come come open for
me I go all right we're heads in
downtown LA it was in it was for some
Jewish God why charity trying to be
racist right now but why is it always
the Jewish charity thing we all have a
Jewish charity story I really do
mine was with uh God what's his name uh
a buddy Buddy Hackett son oh my god oh
my god oh sandy Hackett no but I know
buddy hackett son sandy a cadiz he was a
comic in in Vegas and my worst gig that
I tell everybody is the charity I did
for sandy Hackett was in this a
restaurant it was I think it was a deli
and then uh the stage was literally an
eight-person seat booth yeah they put
plywood on it because you know those
eight seat person boots around yeah they
put plywood on top it that was the stage
oh yeah and then they put like this
karaoke microphone and by the way when I
say karaoke this is like 92 93 or
whatever so we're talking to take
Cosette I'll do you one better okie
machine my Bible I don't know 15 20 it
was a restaurant yeah it's a pavement
you know he paid me he he didn't pay me
cash she goes they uh the charity is uh
three hundred dollars a plate and you
and your girl can eat for free
so I mean if you think about it's like
600 bucks don't sing for me sandy I'm so
dumb and I sit there and I go where are
we gonna perform and they had a speaker
like an amp but they did that you plug
in I go yeah and there was a Myka
well but the problem is that there's no
stage so I'm I'm level with these people
and they're all here so so this is it so
I go what are we gonna do and it was low
ceilings and by the way it was up in a
room and the bar was downstairs
so you could hero buddy downstairs so I
said they're not gonna hear us and this
is not possible
so I see a couch that is four dogs it's
a little mini I'm not kidding on a mini
leather couch for dogs and don't ask me
what I was doing in this opposite room
so I go let me see if this works and I
pulled this little cat so I go up and
pick up the couch and I walk it over and
I stand on it and I go I guess this'll
have to do so I take the mic and I open
for dove and I do 15 20 minutes they all
are lying down sitting down there no
chairs and standing and we do stand up
to their credit they listened they
[ __ ] listen do they laugh and they
laughed and then dove got up and did 45
minutes on that [ __ ] ridiculous couch
on a dog couch holding rushed well you
couldn't so the ceiling was about six
inches above my head did you guys get
paid did not get paid I did it as a
favor to dove he got money cause you say
that he get paid I don't know I can't
I'm sure where was that remember fishing
giggles place where fishing giggles that
sounds like last month
Bryant's that's enough fish restaurant
Oh can't Brian's in Florida yes that
you've done it dressing rooms still the
toilet sure is everybody was performing
chips restaurant yeah it's a it's a fish
restaurant it's a fish and chips
restaurant so you can smell malt vinegar
yeah and uh the green room is a toilet
it literally is you have to Brian
captain Brian brah you sit on the toilet
and there's a sink in front of you and
then someone opens the the bathroom and
goes you're on in five Wow
am i right and people and people are
eating while you're performing
yeah
gideon wooden booths and some of the
audience male that's it like what a
booth like check this out
some people are sitting this way and
they can see you right because their
faces but then there are other people
with their bags have to look at you like
this
yeah it's called off-the-hook comedy
off-the-hook comedy that's the name of
the club you should be in on what's that
island that looks different now though
I've just really changed it if there's
still a big shark although comedy club
that that was the old club is this it
yeah well well there's a column yeah no
it's nice it's nice it's different now
it's a it is of still a fish restaurant
that people are eating while you wait
hold on yeah they are Britney changed
its location updated bro time you were
there when it was a [ __ ] bathroom
when was that 90 no here we go yeah mm
here we go here we've already
established note that you're safe but
you keep you've been there currently you
went there a long time ago yeah but it
was early 2000 oh that's a nice stage
yeah they change it yeah yes I can't I
don't perform in restaurants anymore
well no you you just did that huh oh you
guys did that
no I know about it years ago that was
last season I saw you doing a promo on
Instagram hey get fish and chips and see
me live do you like to fish um see all
you can eat fish and chips and comedy
Thursday's with Bryan Callen three
tickets no buy one get one free
come see the kid I don't like I don't
like any of this I don't like where this
hook line and sinker hook line and
sinker comedy come see the kid live
nothing more depressed by one till you
get 7 free just calm please
all-you-can-eat tartar sauce like any
went like that all-you-can-eat tartar
sauce tartar come see the other half of
fighter in the kid the kid the one
that's not as attractive why are you
white come on wait where's my cameras
got me on this right oh you'll fight
right here shingles
I have shingles stammers why did you let
me touch your knee I'll rub why would
you let me touch while you're watching
my pustules on you I'll beat you up and
that'll give you shingles so don't touch
you and be a that's from here you can
beat me up just don't touch I'm a
good-looking guy I didn't think about
you ever see Brad Pitt like what was
that movie where that he becomes old
dude like Benjamin Benjamin bar Boyd he
was good-looking and then he got older
like mmm yeah like I can see like like
you were you probably cute when you're a
kid like hey how would you bro how would
you describe Ryan looks handsome tough
Oh bright I think that no Bryan Oh yours
yours out here yeah okay choke what how
would you describe right now rough life
rough life had a rough go yeah yeah
JoJo's in the face he wears is a hue or
does this problem was right around his
eye Rogan Rogan and I were talking and
he goes we had a good run
oh yeah yeah I was like what do you mean
he's just you know now you know girls if
you were to date a younger girl the girl
would be like she'd tell her friends and
her friends who go it's true no you're
still good-looking
whatever I do you think so you're still
yeah yeah you're so shingles ain't no
where's my camera the shoot is sleepy I
like the Suns in your eyes yeah yeah
this is my natural oh that's true yeah
just wake up in the morning what do you
look like waking up in the morning
Oh in the morning yeah oh wow you oh
here here's a picture right here you see
the bottom right ages at the red eyes oh
the red eyes hey that one right there
that's more like oh my god oh I got off
the hook County
is a [ __ ] oh I'm sorry vision jumped
that's me
oh man that's real real baby the kids
oh let's keep that I can't talk I sound
like when I drop when I come dust you're
always looking for your hat actually
never saw that movie what was what was
that were ya was the moon Jack with
Robin Williams where he ages super fast
that's right opposite Benjamin Button
penny with my buttons he was he was born
a hundred year old baby well you know
it's pretty rad yeah and then but then
Jack Jack just got old right you know
but no but no his body got old but he
had the insides of a toddler
you know what progeria is right progeria
well that's right yeah do you know what
progeria is I don't say that you know
it's it's it's an aging disease so
children age so a six-year-old can be an
80 year old you know about that
physically their internal that's Jack
bro it's so sad this movie Jack little
kids little kids it's a sad movie dude I
love that movie that was a great movie
yes sad CEO huh
they said movie that was based on a
Brian's life what huh the original it
was supposed to be Robin Williams stars
in Brian face Brian oh like you were no
don't say that didn't listen when you
were in high school did kids run up to
you go what times class start I haven't
young ever you have a teacher recently
it's up until my eyes cut started
falling yeah Oh Brian what do you think
Brian wants to get up like surgery on
his face no no just my eyes my eyes are
look at your eyes you don't want to do
that
look Asian I'm not right back no they
look like you're saying yeah no they're
just gonna take a little the skin off
look the weight already to pull it
already watch be honest okay say
something now okay
no hello hello Joe how are you okay no
no no your eyes okay now ready yeah do
it be do it right though hello how are
you oh that's it that's now get rid of
it
hello how are you hello how are you
welcome welcome
you gotta get the right dog okay welcome
welcome welcome yeah
welcome yeah lugubrious we were not
trying to be mean in any way I thought
we were no I know I was good at fighting
my baldness I just I just shaved it good
for you dude he didn't bite it's
fighting the good fight bye good bye
propecia though oh you do not I got a
hair transplant no you did not but not
but like nine years ago but it didn't
take let me see where it's hanging on to
do me they did like but it didn't work
for me
really so how did you touch it too much
I don't touch it too much you know
shitty here I don't want to do this I'm
gonna go see somebody that I you know me
I really love you man yeah you also hate
him he's always been I do hate okay I
know it's a weird relationship right can
I tell you why to oscillate okay do you
you know why I hate him
cuz boys he always makes promises and he
breaks them he can't keep what what does
that mean everyone you the whole room
what what do you mean provident what
about you make promises when this since
this is an example you son of a [ __ ]
you're spreading a bad rumor he'll know
you always done that in the community of
comic well-known this rumor I'm seeing
gigs for other people yeah I'll give you
a spot what time's your show I'll come
through
I've never ha what time you need me to
pick you up just anything that you with
response I'm not an uber driver on this
you you break you you're
give me a comment of podcasting would be
called Brian Collins how to burn bridges
or burn bridges the burn bridges pop
what am i burning the bridges with a kid
yeah oh that's it burning bridges with
the kid what did I promise you that I
didn't come through on everything what
do we have for anything I've never met
coming up I have to ask you like hey can
I get some stage time on one of your
shows or and you're like oh my god would
love for you and then you would never
pick up my cause or that's a lie you're
me you're making lies nothing that you
do I do opposite you're spreading
vicious bro I and that's why what I'm
successful that should be your
infomercial why you want to be
successful hi I'm Bryan Callen do you
want to be successful well then take my
class whatever I do
don't do it do everything opposite of
what I do and watch your money grow grow
grow this is the don't do don't do what
I do remember I was in a stressful pod
called the fighter in the kid and then I
laugh now look at me bald and bald NOT
bald you [ __ ] old and bald new eyes B
you really think you'd do that what's
that oh I think no no I mean when push
comes to shove yeah I was gonna say I
guarantee I guarantee does it well I'm
thinking about it here so you're a
handsome old man yeah I know you are but
I actually support the I think cause it
goes wrong to me awesome yeah well
that's the problem I'm worried about
that also you can't [ __ ] with your eyes
but I do I don't like that skin around
my eyes all about the nuts I have it
from my mom hanging up here I had that
same skinny right I have the same do you
do you want more time if I were to shave
my nuts yeah it would look like your
eyes his eyes that's what I said
that is where's my camera dog let's see
we should do an episode where you and I
shave our nuts no and then hanging off
his eyes no no we put his eyeballs in it
and then we asked your fans with real or
not his eyes real or not look look look
there is this the surgeon that's what
that dojo Vittorio with
yeah age like fine wine and overnight
yeah Cinderella yeah you turn into the
Tales from the Crypt
yeah no quick bro my mom got old when
she was uh 70 overnight then I looked at
my mom I go you're all like wow she was
68 I was like you want to go to prom
like she was help yeah you it's like
Asians and black people it's the only
life alone
you have no idea yeah and but then you
show up to the house one day and just
boom for tonight then they become old
white people become old finally like
physically they become old but they also
like mentally their life they you know
no you know kids that the predator this
P is like the [ __ ] happened to you
where'd you a rapper also in the night
also though I don't know man what I
don't know about all of that my sister
is married to a black man and you do a
podcast live I do a podcast with him and
he has been young his whole life he
looks the same from high school but now
he's an old black man how old is he he's
51 how do you I'm 27 I don't think
that's a joke I don't think that's true
okay but I don't feel like that's true
Joe how would my face tip against yours
and everyone would be like who's I
didn't know Brian had a son no say Joe I
think though like how do you think Kat
is our intern how like Catholics oh my
god 14:16 right like she just got her
license she's off years old she's 11 she
makes iPhones in her off time no you
stole her from Apple that's crazy
they helped me escape yes crazy though
right is that she was being held hostage
you have a large Filipino audience and
Asian in general okay that made no sense
you know large Filipino audience and
where the what age are you talking about
Asian audience in general Asian honey
why does it have to be specific everyone
just be worldwide Internet
your eyes have to be a huge retirement
following no I do like you can hit every
retirement home don't be sold that's not
got it was a soft foods at 11:00 it's a
number I ain't killin afternoons funny
that's another [ __ ] rumor money stop
spreading rumors
you're not 26 I bet you rush in Florida
like all the retirement no homes have
know Latin people no that doesn't come
see you
yes they do I can do you know why you're
alright is literally 100 percent Asian I
have it on good authority [ __ ]
literally I'm gonna thority [ __ ] end
of the day your parents are you ready
your audiences your parents your fans of
mine and they don't even go to your no
they're not yeah go to your show yes
they do
yeah yeah they do they love me you got
shingles be can be you know and your
parents look younger than you rub a puss
on give us some current event to Joe you
know here's the cool thing man getting
ready to go on tour again after the
special drops in June so Netflix special
drops in June what's it called uh we
haven't came up with a decision you know
no I'm poor man's Bryan Callen [ __ ]
burn just so hard just gross burning
people I love that [ __ ] the Asian
poor-man's Brian can I'm going to put
subtitles so you can read it what does
that mean because you can't hear anymore
you're old you're an old man you and I
are the same basically I Bryan Callen
and I hope you enjoyed my comedy is a
terrible [ __ ] impression of me bro I
would I have funny stories that's close
knit it's not close to I love for sure
hey so you're it you said in June
joe-joe Carly the kid oops I just beat
Michelle how do I sound what I'm
actually having sex before I die I just
[ __ ] again that is so disgusting
I know all right
for an offense right now all right I got
to go I got stuff to do I got it I got
okay
so Aaron Carter is back in the news
defending Michael Jackson who is he
Aaron Carter defending Michael Jackson
is like Steve Bremerton defending
Michael Jackson no one knows who the
[ __ ] Carter's brother right from the
Backstreet Boys this is the original
Justin Bieber then why they have a
picture of Nick Carter there that's his
no no they identical no he's younger
also his hair it does here green and he
also came out as bisexual right yes yes
he did he's also sick but I'm not sure
what he said he's messed up in there
yeah he's got some problems yeah
Tweaker yes yeah Wade Robson came out
and insinuated on Twitter that Aaron
Carter was also molested by Michael
Jackson for sure yeah
and TMZ reached out to Aaron Carter to
see if he had anything he wants to say
to which he defended Michael Jackson and
now he wants to soon fight Wade Robson
just saw a light in the ring
like punching man yeah he's just saying
like I want to fight yeah well Aaron the
car didn't have much to do so I'm sure
he gives them attention oh there he goes
he got one on TMZ this is him mm-hmm
he also claims that the HBO documentary
team reached out him for an interview
and want to pay him six figures for it
okay
is this the video of sort of blood
Pierce jackson liked his video of him
defending Michael Jackson yes is this
the video here or no yeah we cuz he went
on was it Wendy Williams he's not doing
well he has her all but pay attention
first your reaction to leaving Neverland
my reaction to leaving Neverland was
incredible
I remember having the time of my life
with Michael about 15 years old and just
sitting down with me you know being like
you know this is kind of like what you
got to do Aaron in your future and you
know just stay focused and you didn't
listen but your perfection no you did
not listen now
one vocal coaches lad you remember what
he's saying here did he tell you the
neck tattoo yeah I realized Michael he
told you to do crack he told you to suck
someone this is what you do Aaron you
can't crack you're a grown man and when
Michael Jackson was alive you are
backing him you are up his ass
legitimate kissing his ass
you are there to testify for him to
monitor Oh even though he didn't know he
dies you decide that that's a good time
to come that come out no what you're
doing is you're actually stomping on an
icon and a legends grave you're stomping
on his grace you know you know he's not
doing well one two shooting this video
in a car with the oh [ __ ] bar nice cars
don't have those oh [ __ ] you see that
bar so good I yeah yeah you don't see
that in a BMW now murasa Maseratis don't
have those no no don't be materialistic
maybe he just likes you know who has
those Brian Brian is that no I'm in my
test so much wad watched him fight
though what else we got so Felicity
Huffman and Lori Loughlin have been
indicted and Felicity was arrested
yesterday for basically paying a company
to bribe their way for her daughter's to
get into school and what school was it
was it si si yeah yep both of their you
get your deci yeah this has been how I
hate to tell you guys this been
happening forever everybody know we're
tied up hold on
do you think George Bush got into Ivy
League school with his gray well no he
got an ivory screw because there's a
legacy thing and it's but Dad had so
much money no that's what he said so you
give money to the endowment 100% and
schools have always had that's what I'm
saying always had I've always given
place to certain students who who you
know can can I got that I'll take you
four minutes know their dads donate the
endowment this is very different this is
very different
no I'm just saying no no well it's not
different it's a how it's not different
is there has been alumni when their kids
are coming up and they pay
the boosts are something to get their
kids into the school even though they
don't qualify it okay this has been
going on forever okay so some but when
you take same with sports do when you
take somebody when you have somebody who
takes the tests for you when you have
somebody who when you say oh they want
an athlete and you superimposed your
daughter's head on to a [ __ ] somebody
who's rowing and submit that as that's
my athlete all fishes was cheating on
such a high no Beyonc I think it's the
fault on the same umbrella weird yeah
there's a motivation for the university
and it's it's a motivation of finances
to get these kids sure the only thing
others pain it yeah this would this
wasn't the university these were
individuals like coaches and and college
admissions people who were in on the
getting private you know for Shawn's you
know so they were being bribed yeah and
what I'm saying is that there it is true
100% that if you go to Harvard and your
dad has a lot of money and he went to
Harvard in together but you definitely
have a much better chance of getting in
there's no question and and so that the
merits of that can be definitely debated
but in this case this is this is when I
saw this I was like I can't no [ __ ] in
sports you actually call you kid there's
kids who had no business being there
won't be cause they're good at football
they somehow got in don't go to the
classes then but they pass oh yeah
people going and sitting in there and
how they pass them how they pass they
generally corrupt is what you're saying
n-c-double-a scrub all of its career
yeah that's a big scheme right there but
this is they just got caught this
happens in every Universal so this guy
that was running this for-profit college
preparation company and he I think from
2011 to 2018 he no 25 mil so in that
sense like it was basically I'll get you
in well we'll figure out a way to get
your kids grades up in a fake way or get
them to think that they're athletes
they're all these tricks we can do to me
it's like you gotta know you're gonna
get caught eventually yeah right you
gotta know right I'm Laurel said I'm
sorry to interrupt you but I'm worth it
like like the whole bribery and getting
them in what I'm mad at the most is you
put your face
as an athlete on a pitcher and became a
rower like our you fight like your whole
life you're gonna live that lie and tell
your kids like you know mommy's to row
like you forgetting you're gonna live
that you know whole life like I don't
mind about lying about the school
because whatever you have to do to get
through school it's [ __ ] anyways a
lie about it being a rower that's weird
but but I get good here's my picture you
to show your kids that picture like the
sports is weird but I will could come in
from playing division one football
seeing the kids who got in and had no
business being at that school and they
got their degrees i I think I viewed
college is different like if someone
came up here that came in I have a three
year old and then when he's let's say 18
they go hey man for a hundred grand
tiger and gear to Stanford like I'll pay
or get your home yeah no problem yeah we
but the problem with that also is this
if they go you don't have the grades
really so yeah yeah no problem that's
why you do have rules against that kind
of money the influence of money so so
that not just the elites get into school
the idea behind the university is you
earn your place through your grades and
three or sports you know in the photo in
football at least these guys were good
football players they had a skill in
this case we're just talking about
people who had the money to cheat in
every way and get in so these guys here
it's were famous or if your parents so
what I'm saying is that in at least in
football or alumni these guys earn the
right no no no they earn the right to
play foot that what I'm saying they
didn't earn the right to get a dick
either way what I'm saying 100 percent
oh what I'm and that's corrupt and the
n-c-double-a is corrupt for sure okay it
doesn't mean that this isn't also kinda
outrageous and I think it falls on the
same umbrella but was it that I'm like
you know here's my argument with college
okay
what's more corrupt what they did which
is really [ __ ] shitty right or the
fact that they make these kids
mandatory to play basketball before they
can go play for the NBA these kids can
no longer leave high school and become
professionals actually they got rid of
the rule but but how many is how many is
it they hold that office for a while ten
years they made it mandatory they pretty
much stopped the
nets and the and the Kobe's and all
these kids from leaving high school
because they were like well [ __ ] we're
missing how much money on this yeah
we're losing how many jerseys how many
Garnett jerseys coulda sold in North
Carolina will be dragons we just sold it
at Duke like you know take it take it
away from bats well your basketballs big
you know but that's it football it's way
more yeah you're right snaps wait what's
right stop well think about the college
ball games like thing about much much
the the [ __ ] Notre Dame does those
kids don't see a dime and they have to
be in school for two years yeah a ball
you have to be in school for two years
so look that's that's corrupted things
to worry about
I mean this isn't the end of the world
but oh no these rich kids got in and
you're like tight but then it was it was
blatant cheating and more importantly
talk about sending a bad message to your
kids like we're gonna we're in a now you
do not have to take the test or compete
you also didn't have to play a sport but
we'll get you in under those two 4,000
kids don't know about it you know that a
lot them didn't know it's all oh yeah
has to go to summer school this year and
I'm so hold is that he's 15 and it
pisses me off because the Dean was like
he can't go into the 11th grade unless
he goes to summer school and repeat
history and I'm pissed because we always
go on vacation together and now he's
[ __ ] us yeah so I'm about to make a
donation and see if we could do some
other way to get out of this that's
that's [ __ ] up right no what about
with this
this lady is you are gonna make your
daughter's tell everybody that they were
rowers for the law right you [ __ ]
wait like how do you sit at the table
with your kid and be like look you're a
rower now and now you get to tell your
kids that's what I mean hey would you
you want to go on vacation so you're
gonna try to work something out with the
Dean so he can make it up in another way
yes but I can also and myself will still
repeat his right and I will find a way
to do that right so so what I'm saying
is that you still you can't but no
matter what you can use it you can come
up with other examples of cheating but
this is blatant cheating yeah and so
it's all blade it's it's horrible you're
putting everything on the same level and
I don't know that you can talk to me
it's all cheating it is cheating like
Shuko I should jog it back what about
the LSU coach who just got fired because
they said he brought they have him on
record bribing a player but he got fired
he got fired so it's cheating yeah you
put it but it happens at every school
you don't say it so they so they pay
you're just saying just isn't a bad
dealer it's not a big deal because this
happens at from sports to regular kids
it's happening all over non-stop 24/7
yeah this is college life so that that
kid who so the kid who they make money
off of when they sells Georgia LSU yeah
he's not gonna be able to play
basketball because the coach gave his
family money who he didn't have money
where is it where is the cheating in
that though how is he cheating because
the the school the school paid the kid
to come to that to that University yeah
but he's that's kind of an isn't that an
open-ended thing where in other words
this kid is a great athlete they there's
a competition for this kid to school
with the with the most incentive gets to
take that kid so it's an open playing
field right I'm talking about this this
situation when you're getting your
daughter in by literally essentially
saying that this is that this you're
you're really what you're doing in this
case is you're saying she don't have any
skills but I'm gonna actually
superimpose photographs and I'm going to
put in place an avatar that's not even
my kid that's what we're talking only
some of them some of them they just they
were time with the test yeah some of the
yeah that's not taking that's a handicap
that's the exception the exception with
that whatever you guys are focus on that
most of the people if you look at the
the thing what's going on here is they
just impose grades and tests to get them
through yeah so this is basically what
you're saying is that this has been
going on forever and these guys just got
call cuz they got a little carried away
and too much of it yeah and to and
[ __ ] frankly to ball how did they get
guys do we know what was an FBI sting
the FBI was like watching how the FBI
guys sad people tip them off you know
people are like the [ __ ] you know the
FBI's got different divisions that watch
this I wonder what what [ __ ] [ __ ]
started telling her friend I got in cuz
my mom know so when you do this from
2011 to 2018 and it's this big a
business for you but that
I passed it with a chair ventually some
nonprofit people who are taking tests
and you're paying them
you got ringers eventually somebody's
gonna follow yes you use can't you can't
away with something for eight years
there's a good run a twenty five million
dollars pretty good run yeah algebraic
and you know what their time out pulling
all the diplomas who do with oh man when
the piper the piper will be paid all
this right the piper we have today is
that though so let's say let's say you
you have a [ __ ] twenty eight-year-old
son who got diploma from Stanford
he's now let's say works for Facebook
he's one of the co people at Facebook
he's making millions they'll do we I
pull you did we had a holier does it
matter it's like all right I don't think
I'd like to see that they probably
challenged him quit house bear see cuz
he was talking so much [ __ ] to his kids
like I went through college you got to
do it look what your dad yeah after
college and then it's kids gonna be like
hey Dad you think all Brides were
channeled through a fake charity oh gosh
it's who wanted disability they work
routed onto the crew team even though
they've never done crew oh my god
daughter cheat when you're helping your
daughter cheat on exams I'm football
like I wouldn't do that that's [ __ ] up
if you're helping your daughter your
child cheat on an entrance exam yeah I
got a problem with that yeah I mean III
well I don't know what the penalty
should be but you're gonna get caught
and believe it what about all those what
about all the athletes man they ain't
getting in through with entries but at
least they're playing a sport I mean I
don't know okay at all because they
won't say one my problem with with the
end with pro sports is that these kids a
lot of them just leave with bad knees
maybe some CTE and no education I got a
problem with that yeah 100% I got a
problem with that and and there's been
plenty of they've been books written
about this and plenty people know a lot
more about this than I do but the NCAA
is a corrupt it's corrupt
yeah a hundred percent but again this is
I'm talking about a different subject
here in a way I mean this is just a big
ball than the same in I think this is
different III don't see a difference
know why although it's cheating is
cheating now they're all taking spots
from kids who could have got in
legitimately
Brian I'm not kidding
a player can play bass okay you're
seeing this to be ready to play their
sport okay you'll be taking a position
in the classroom yeah from Seoul he's
qualified who didn't get in exactly I
think the thing I think that every
college that's a huge that makes that
much money on their sports program we
all know that that's bait they're
basically professional athletes not
getting paid right so so at least make
it least we know that and at least they
know that and everybody knows that but
that doesn't make it okay I'm not saying
I'm not saying it makes it okay I'm
saying well this is I'm making a
distinction and what I'm saying is I
think this is such blatant cheating and
so like so like you're getting people to
take your exams for you you're you're
you're getting them to be recruited on
the crew team you're paying off the crew
coach and saying recruit them even
though they've never done a day a crew
this I do think that's a difference
I do think how do I have far part yeah
it's just a look either way I have a
problem with both but you know you like
college hoops it's you like March
Madness yeah College it to get into
college admission is so competitive this
what happens why is it cheating in the
Olympics yeah because it's so [ __ ]
Kipp ultra competitive yeah people are
gonna find loopholes yeah it's human
nature
yeah the NFL UFC professor Schwartz it's
it's so [ __ ] ultra competitive
keeping an achievement yeah here's my
theme real quick and I'm just gonna make
a statement real quick all right parents
if your kids can't go to college maybe
they just shouldn't go to college if
they're not good in high school man
schools not for everybody
like I know myself I got I got a bunch
of money saved for my son in college but
right now it doesn't look good he's
gonna buy a really nice car with that
[ __ ] he's creative I'm gonna support it
cuz I was creative yeah school is not
for everybody
no yeah I knew I wanted to be a comic
when I was like 11 years old it's like
bro I knew that's what I'm and I know
that my son is creative he's gonna find
something I'm not gonna force him to go
to college just because you got a degree
doesn't mean you're gonna be successful
a lot of these people come out of
college with degrees and they don't even
[ __ ] use it
here in Hollywood yeah [ __ ] ton of
people like you know what your journey
is you know what your [ __ ] road is
whatever it is that you want to do
creatively yeah you'll figure it out
College does not tell you to do that no
it does it yeah so stop if your kids are
[ __ ] stupid in high school they're
stupid in college right yeah so don't do
this dumb [ __ ] preach what's gonna
happen when she goes off degree she's
gonna be stupid with a degree you just
ruined your daughter's life so I'm glad
you're going to jail you're a [ __ ]
idiot go to prison though huh should the
parents go to prison oh I'm not I don't
know things you're gonna bomb the same
would you just should they go to prison
no they shouldn't or should they pay
huge fines new community service yes
let's put the roof I'm not a guy who
advocates for a lot of prison time but
should the full house hot girl be
imprisoned no people house yeah let me
get what else yes Jerry give us two more
do you want
so Johnny Depp is suing Amber Heard for
defamation and he's trying to take her
450 million dollars right now damn
Johnny
I don't why you ever heard there I said
it yeah I don't even know who that roof
of it now really yes he Johnny teams
team Johnny Depp's team actually went
back and took surveillance videos from
their home from the time that they were
living together and found 87 videos of
her abusing him yes her throwing a vada
vodka bottle at him so badly that one of
his fingers almost came off she looks
spicy she's a scumbag man and I don't
know who she is
I knew it I've seen a lot of stuff I've
heard too many things bad stuff and then
her career definitely took off again
after John yeah after the Johnny Depp
the message would ensure make like a
jillion dollars off the divorce she made
good good amount of change and she
donated it to women's organization she's
donate all of it yes to Maya what kind
of like domestic abuse are gonna really
and now this is coming out that she was
the abuser yes yes wow she's a
calculated [ __ ] Brian can i I'm sorry
to interrupt you yeah but usually when
people do [ __ ] like that when they
donate to a fund like that it's to mask
it's like magician Rattus it's like
here's a smoke screen not abused it's
not like religious people well not only
that I got another one Oh God who was it
with uh with uh Penn State
remember that coach and dusky okay he
knew all that she was happening right
when I went with before this before it
came out if you went to Nike if you went
to the 90 thing in Portland or whatever
organ organ yeah they had a send
Sandusky building and guess what it was
were known each building had a theme
right so Tiger Woods had the I don't
know so some theme you know to be like
mix kit I'm making this up all right mix
Kids Foundation Chinese or whatever he's
not Chinese a very racist Asian Bo
Jackson had you know the the black kids
foundation just making this racist
because he's black if he was a kid Tiger
Woods with Taiwanese I believe and you
just said Chinese so then but then you
go to Sandusky's building and guess what
it said Children's Foundation
Wow well that's how he did it check this
out right this is before anything came
out on the news so he built that ten
years before hear anything [ __ ] which
means that's the smokescreen she's a
said he bets calculated moving the worth
give the money nice amazing yes I say
some yeah I would let her throw me
around
oh she's a strategic that's not a good
thing man what we're doing is yeah it's
not about your dick it's about yeah
Johnny can you think about Johnny for a
second you almost lost finger all right
I feel for him I would dress up as a
pirate' letter
oh my I'd let her kick me around put
some mascara on like Johnny does a
[ __ ] seven scarves ten necklaces I
let her kick me like beetlejuice
outrageous
looks she looks like such a federalism
Oh [ __ ] to me Opie did I think
beetlejuice yeah thank you
yeah and I corrected you like its father
good speech see I feel like that's up
for debate
no it's not oh really he's not Chinese
but he's dad's black mom's trying not
Chinese which makes mom is white which
makes you races hook up look this up -
hold on you want to put money on this
you want to bet Raleigh's blood what
Rollie mines mines $20,000 more than
yours but do you paint
so is that Daytona it no don't worry
about it all right it's a scheduler look
wait that looks like it's expensive you
don't know what expensive looks like hey
go get some water over top Roger what
are you ready hold on are we gonna make
the bed good Taiwanese I'll just say
he's not Chinese no you're a pick one
wait who's one what is that you gotta
pick that you can't want anyone like one
of these - yeah bro home ah it's you
idiot I will go with Taiwan your words
is um say Korean he's neither he's
neither wait dummy's he's Thai oh I
didn't see anything closer races Oh
closer racist joke we're Thai is in
there I knew the word Thai was in what
he wants why you know what's not in that
word Chinese funnel there it is but mom
sometimes can be confused as Chinese
could touch it my shingle shingles spot
all right what else we got that was
funny
come on I can't believe you said that
very racist so the Catholic Diocese of
New York wants Pete Davidson to
apologize for his r.kelly Catholic
priests touching kids joke [ __ ] that
when if Catholic Church comes completely
clean and holds all those people
accountable all those [ __ ] priests
they protected forever yeah that they
move them to different church yeah then
then then then maybe
comic Pete Davidson to apologize get the
[ __ ] outta ya what stop molesting kids
yeah you owe more respect
yeah let's uh let's fire some people
once how's that I've never fired anybody
yeah the entire somebody recently just
like go on Oh recently one guy was held
was actually had to face charges
yeah but if you look at you watch the
movie spotlight or if you look at the
history of the thousands oh oh my god
the tens of thousands be and this new
this new book that came out with this
guy who embedded himself a gay
journalist who embedded himself in from
the info Italian journalist and said
this is a this is essentially lost a
medal and and and the rest are are
pedophiles and the gay men are terrified
that pedophiles are gonna expose them
and the pedophiles are group and it's
just a vicious cycle of a vicious cycle
yeah
so you got to come clean I think the
Catholicism and Christianity has a
fuckload to offer I have a lot of
respect for it but at the same time this
church like most institutions can get
corrupt it is corrupt and you had a lot
of pedophiles hiding behind the cloth so
until they come clean on that yeah and
you know what you guys should have done
not made any headlines with this topic
no she should have been the first ones
to Jesus like the [ __ ] down cool yeah we
have some good press yeah you just
opened up a bag of worms
music allegations over 2,600 priests in
Church workers across the u.s. have been
revealed by 96 diocese and it's just in
the past months Wow
oh come on well if you give us one more
this one that was depressed super
negative are you made this post Odell
Beckham jr.
going to Queen Cleveland Brown there's
not football your football fan I mean I
cam I'm a football fan they from Seattle
what else you got the Odell Beckham jr.
is going to the Browns they have Jarvis
Landry and they have him now and they
have hunt as the running back and they
have one of the best quarterbacks in the
league
they're ballin and they're in Cleveland
so that's I don't know what what do you
think I think they're McGarrett I think
the playoffs Cleveland is plagued but
back in the day Broglie they went seven
and nine last year yeah they're gonna be
good okay Baker Mayfield threw me [ __ ]
good
Odell Beckham then he got hunt as a
running back that yet chubbs they
they're stacked man yep yeah they're
stacked yes Dumas shake you mean give me
one more you don't want any bad ones
right like not violent ones as well if
it's fun violent you know this out of
all the pods I've done the racists and
the kid is my favorite the racists in
the kid number one we were great we love
you thank you u.s. women's soccer team
sues for equal pay their the popular
ones actually we're better than the men
now hold up they are better than the men
as far as playing of their women and
they're more popular yeah and they're
more successful if this is a debate
that's also happens if they're if
they're if the market you know I says
you're worth it then the marketplace
says you're worth it but I believe in
the marketplace why you're not getting
more money because you're women or any
[ __ ] off and I have you earned it okay
if you how it's Morgan's earned it yeah
if you're if you're worth more then you
get more money more a draw then yes man
that let the marketplace like dogs don't
yeah I just yeah this cake or transgenic
gay comic who said oh wow this gay comic
was like he's a comic and he's not good
but he was on TV and he was saying them
he's from New York or something goes
look 10% or 15% of our 20% he said
something like that of the population is
LGBTQ which is not true and he goes so
if you have a show if you have a show
you better have if you have a common
show 20% of your performers better be
gay straight trans and I was like
[ __ ] this what he said oh it's like
mm-hmm
be funny first you [ __ ] more yeah
that doesn't make any sense is that
people are people I don't go by raising
or jewel Aaron are you funny that's
right yeah these girls are beasts
arguing that there's so much better than
the men but no one really pays attention
women sake even though they're killing
it but you said earlier you said they
are good amongst other women can they
beat the men's team Bob god no they're
way funner to watch those Oprah worse
they're also the men suck our men's gas
sucks
well it's also soccer so we don't care
in America but have you heard the thing
with with that that what's that the
female movie the comic movie supposed to
be killing it the one that's not really
funny but no no not funny the [ __ ]
Marvel movie was it Captain Marvel
Captain Marvel have you heard the
conspiracy theory on this so right it's
the first female lead in a superhero
movie and it's the biggest open ever for
a female lead there's been some
conspiracy around where that's not true
having seen the pictures of the theaters
know it's not that crowded like
biggest-ever women's rights me to
movement check out the movie and it's
not the case Wow but their bleak in it
like it is that's that's what's going on
the underground there they have the
holes game I don't even know what movie
were talking about Captain Marvel this
one yeah that's out yeah yeah I guess it
is up and it's a they say out to this
huge success but is that really hurt no
that's a very large don't buy it
don't buy it I've never seen anything I
haven't even seen a trailer for this
yeah that's the point I'm still watching
Iron Man to quality movie though Okoye
you're a good man
I don't want to end on that I can't win
on that he's gonna gonna get outta here
I have to go do press for my special
comp you Marc Maron
yeah I Love You Man you're going on tour
he said oh yeah I'm on tour Renato and
are you on tour right now yeah I I got
started what is this here because I'm
better observes tonight yes okay so a
vine 14 shows we're about to add two
more 14 yeah Wow 14 how many days in a
row uh-huh how many I mean that's two
weeks you they're two weeks straight
so yeah let's start Wednesday until
Sunday take two days off and do
Wednesday through Sunday again holy [ __ ]
dude 14 shows I think we're gonna add
two more to your beat
oh no we did add two more right Joe oh
so it's gonna be 16 so 16 shows at the
maybe I'll come to us at one of them can
you
I'm dalian I was lying man
I know but seriously you promise all the
fire this guy comes through I want to
come I will say this and this is how
we're gonna end this okay this is an
honest guy no no well about me an honest
guy he's a man of his word like he's a
hustler no no I'm not gonna bust his ass
and that's why he's hugely successful a
liar burn bridges oh yeah that's why you
don't have a good watch Wow yeah that's
why your face is old that's why of
shingles that's why you ever hold a lie
you guys are always like this like ah
you're tense all right listen I gotta go
I love so your vine 14 shows you know
quite calm Jay okay why calm boom he has
a podcast coming out I got a new special
Netflix on that coming out dude I got a
cartoon coming out and I also got a book
that's coming out Jesus oh you're a
hustler
I'm see me City Kansas City you see
Kensie improv and then I'll be at
Philadelphia at the end of the month
helium and then Calgary after that I got
a run I love you guys the reads love you
man
Miami I'll see you this Friday Saturday
One Show Friday to show Saturday Miami
improv next week Milwaukee Turner hall
once yo Friday One Show Saturday then
the last week of March I'm at Washington
DC DC improv Thursday Friday Saturday
get tickets now for Brian myself to fat
K calm love you guys this fighter kid
we're out love it